-He is the most nominated artist
at this year's
Latin Grammy Awards.
Here with the TV debut
of their new song "Indigo,"
please welcome
Camilo and Evaluna!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ ¿Cómo puede ser
que uno sueñe ♪
♪ Con alguien que ni siquiera
ha conocido? ♪
♪ No sé si es posible
pero yo llevo ya ♪
♪ Mucho tiempo soñando contigo ♪
♪ Y cuando la historia
parecía completa ♪
♪ Le diste una vuelta de 360 ♪
♪ Tú eres el 50 de mi 50 ♪
♪ Y ahora todo huele
y sabe mejor ♪
♪ Porque llegó a mi vida ♪
♪ El amor de mi vida ♪
♪ Yo se lo pedí al de arriba ♪
-♪ Pero contigo
se le fue la mano ♪
-♪ Y qué buena suerte la mía ♪
♪ Gané sin jugar la lotería ♪
♪ La falta que me hacías ♪
-♪ Contigo una vida
llegó temprano y ♪
-♪ La ra la la la, la la ra ♪
♪ La ra la la, la la ra ♪
♪ La ra la la,
la la ra ♪
♪ La la ♪
♪♪
-♪ Si pienso que vienes,
tiemblo como un flan ♪
♪ Para hacer contigo
ya tengo mil plans ♪
♪ Pedacito mío,
mi café con pan ♪
♪ Soy el presidente
de tu club de fans ♪
-♪ Contigo ya no hay
martes trece ♪
♪ Prepara el cachete
pa' que te lo bese ♪
♪ Y es que lo bueno
toma tiempo a veces ♪
♪ Yo tengo que esperarte
nueve meses y yo ♪
-♪ Voy a tenerte
muy cerca de mí ♪
♪ Pegados como con pegante y ♪
-♪ Voy a comprarte
una gafas de sol ♪
♪ Porque el futuro
se ve brillante ♪
-♪ Porque llegó a mi vida ♪
♪ El amor de mi vida ♪
♪ Yo se lo pedí al de arriba ♪
-♪ Pero contigo
se le fue la mano ♪
-♪ Y qué buena suerte la mía ♪
♪ Gané sin jugar la lotería ♪
♪ La falta que me hacías ♪
-♪ Contigo una vida
llegó temprano ♪
-♪ Porque llegó a mi vida ♪
♪ El amor de mi vida ♪
♪ Yo se lo pedí al de arriba ♪
-♪ Pero contigo
se le fue la mano ♪
-♪ Y qué buena suerte la mía ♪
♪ Gané sin jugar la lotería ♪
♪ La falta que me hacías ♪
-♪ Contigo una vida
llegó temprano y ♪
♪ La ra la la la, la la ra ♪
♪ La ra la la, la la ra ♪
♪ La ra la la,
la la ra ♪
-♪ La la ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]